[Music]
all right so we're all very familiar
with George Floyd yes now the officers
have sense and all of them have been
charged how do you pronounce the guy's
eyes is this Chauvin or Chavan Chauvin
children like a chauvinist pig
so thank you
so all of them have gotten locked up
which was great after the protesting the
other three officers also got charged
however one of the officers Thomas Lane
set up a crowd a crowd funding I think
it was through GoFundMe and he actually
was able to pay his $750,000 bail oh
[ __ ] through a GoFundMe there's that
many supporters free is that how he got
out online
you only need to post a percentage of
bill right so you didn't have to get 250
thought it says he oh I think as soon as
he paid us having hired $50,000 cash
bail yeah I think it's so he paid 75
grand
I think I'm sure he raised a [ __ ] ton
because there's a lot of people like the
seal on their post and I look at this
crazy [ __ ] where people are like sorry
girl funniest in support of like these
people or like for the people that
committed like like good for them the
other officers are still in jail because
they have like well showman's is a 1.25
million dollar bail and then the other
two also have a 750 thousand dollar bail
well the other two aren't white so
that's why they probably not getting the
support from the other way well Shogun's
wife there's I'm saying he's the one
that got out thomas lanús Yeah right
okay yeah because when you go through a
bail bond it's only like 10% of it or
whatever right and also you pay them and
then they handle the bail [ __ ] so with
that if you commit murder and then you
pay bail you could get out what does
manslaughter not every single one second
degree or second room I mean depending
on what you're charged with
um if it's murder they're not gonna let
you go oh right the judge will be like
this like blah blah blah without bail
because not everybody and so not
everyone gets fit actually bill is such
a stupid thing
well I mean it you're innocent until
proven guilty though so I don't think
it's that stupid if you're not guilty
but the part that's I've been we gotta
pay money for it yeah the part that's
weird it's like uh okay you are innocent
until proven guilty
you're innocent but why are you in a why
are you in a cage why are you like you
know I give the case isn't over
yeah you need this guy if you let them
out if they post bail and they let him
out this guy can go and [ __ ] up all
kinds of evidence so you know I mean
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's on us if he's
guilty
oh you know at school you're gonna find
like mean they didn't get in a fight at
school or something I beat your ass
you're winning yeah thank you and let's
say the prison the principal grabs both
of us he's not gonna go go back the next
three or four periods that I'll see you
guys later
then I can go and like you race the
blood marks I can go talk to them three
other friends to conspire
oh yeah Nadine kay mr. Nye shows me to
spread this lie that's impossible where
you be my ass and then I go back to and
then like now I have a whole case bill
against the name whereas at school the
principal goes are you to come to the
office and you're just sitting there for
hours yeah I mean that works if your
kill I mean that's a scenario if you're
guilty but if you're not guilty that's
[ __ ] up that you're in a room not able
to talk to anyone to defend yourself so
you kind of have to be as fair as
possible but you don't know sometimes it
is wrestle exactly so you can't you go
that's why it's innocent until proven
guilty
yeah yeah stuff right I mean not if
you're not guilty well I mean apparently
he paid the full cash amount Wow yeah
early of $750,000 yeah and then okay I
just looked up and now you can school
this I'm very I don't really know how
bail works exactly but according to this
I was according to google coordinate
jefes funds are returned to the
defendant once the proceedings are over
and the defendant has not forfeited the
bail by failing to appear for court for
court date or by violating a condition
of the bit of the bail I think the easy
part
the back the crazy part is that he got
to do a GoFundMe yes he raised funds
through GoFundMe and then he got out
through paying it in cash and then if
after if after the proceedings are over
he gets that all that money back so I
talked to a cop friend who also talked
to a bunch of other detectives and other
judges and they're saying what they
charged like obviously he shouldn't have
the neon George Floyd's neck and that
[ __ ] looks [ __ ] crazy and there's
just years and years of police brutality
that's all being put and we're trying to
serve justice based off one case
but from a lot of people that are in law
enforcement and understand how the legal
system works what they explained to me
is that there is no way that they can
prove this is second-degree murder
because you have to have beyond a
reasonable doubt that he intended to
kill him since because they can't prove
that a lot of people in law enforcement
the judicial system think this whole
entire thing is a PR move to just calm
everyone down and what's really gonna
happen is he's gonna get off because the
charges escalated I'm probably not drop
the charges after everyone chills the
[ __ ] out and no one cares anymore
they're gonna drop the charges and
reduce them I think people will still
care it actually that'll probably induce
more riots they [ __ ] up so bad by
doing that though because I said that I
said that the other day was like when
they they escalated the charge the
second degree they don't know what they
don't know what that means
and then that's also wiping there he's
able to get money because I guess people
that are on the other side they're like
hey why is this guy getting second
degree if you're really going by the
books it shouldn't be second degree so
that's part of why there are people
actually donating to because we all feel
like you should be charged with first
degree murder we feel like yeah right
but then how do you prove that in a
court of law like that's where it gets
murky well okay so you got are you
talking about like charges gonna be
dropped on all the cops I don't know
they're just saying whatever they're
doing charged with and being show them
has to be proven right right okay I
definitely see the the charges
potentially being dropped on like the
other three but if they stuck with third
degree for the main guy they would it
right he would have been able to punish
him yeah yeah but I think like I mean I
think it'd be so silly to not just like
you know even like even if it is like
two people like saying it's a PR move
right like I think like it'd be a bad
move too soon to let the the main guy
off well not let them up but reduce the
charges right like drop it back down to
third degree yeah manslaughter or
something a.m. whatever though the next
one's down a lot of people online like
part of it the black lives movement
they're like hey stop trying to get them
to increase the sentence because it's
they don't have the evidence for that
that you can't people don't know how and
these charges you need a judge to pretty
much sign off on
right so most judges based off however
many years in history they've been seen
like trials they look at in the light
[ __ ] I'm getting so much [ __ ]
pressure till I pretty much go okay this
is second-degree murder or first three
or whatever and then like all the other
judge homies are like [ __ ] I wouldn't
even know what I would do if I were you
because I can see why you feel this
pressure but I would never sign off on
that yeah I thought I mean I thought
people on Twitter pushing for
first-degree and everybody else mad
people were like you know do not do that
yeah there's no way that's gonna stick
though there's smart people that know
right right I wish we could see the
trial alive like oh geez him since that
dude like was on Twitter but they were
like before he actually got there like
to actually either committed they had
the people explaining everything even
like for the Ahmad case they had like
the breakdown when they went to trial
and basically was like all the people
they're like oh this guy was running
here like basically like there's no way
that it would have been like
self-defense and like the broadcasts all
like live on Twitter well justice should
be a course taught in public school yeah
a lot of things you should know your
rights are walk it out on but you should
know what your rights are you should
know how the Constitution works with
what your bill rights are good lord man
so sucks sometimes that's the part of
the system that I'm like what like
things are doing this for a reason like
they don't teach you how to do your
taxes they don't teach you how to do all
the things that like can help you thrive
in in life and then they don't teach you
what your rights are everything's in
legalese that you weren't taught how to
read that [ __ ] so you got to hire
somebody who's expensive to [ __ ] and
they do that [ __ ] on purpose
damn straight fees they know you can't
afford to hire somebody correct yeah man
like even like I mean I've talked about
this before like buying a house is such
a [ __ ] that I'm not any of it work
that's like why don't they teach you
this [ __ ] in school it's so silly
because everyone is who have a house
it's it crazy everyone has to pay taxes
that's how they keep jobs like you know
there was like a where you talking about
like a law that was gonna give house and
then like H&R Block and TurboTax and
people they lobbied against it and both
houses
voted to voted it down because it was
supposed to be a law that was gonna make
taxes simple so they basically would say
you already know how much you owe they
already know why do we all have to
configure a all the [ __ ] but they and
but you know all these TurboTax well
these places didn't want that
is there any country in the world that
teaches people how to do taxes anything
like the important stuff important stuff
probably not well we all have to seek
information obviously that's the lesson
it's like yeah there is a system that
completely sucks and they don't want you
to [ __ ] win and so you have to teach
yourself if you want to win but I know
how to do long division and diagram
census how about that how about that at
least we live in an age where you can
find that information and easily you
know that let's actually that's at least
a plus it is but it's also like you
shouldn't have to work this hard just to
live a normal life yeah sure no back in
the day I was like I have a question
better go to library check out a book
who's gonna do that nerds I don't know
you go these go online which is pretty
cool
but now you go online it's like I don't
know what to believe anymore you can't
even brah you can't believe anything not
even like video evidence of [ __ ] well
deep fakes are getting so real it's like
oh I don't know editing they cut before
like something happens before and then
they show the reaction like all kinds of
yeah like the Ahmad case they they had a
new video of the guy calling like the
n-word like five times
so it's like damn like they thank God
they have other videos coming out to
show like that it was racially charged
ah
that's crazy yeah we got to rely on our
own videos cuz in the body cam footage
always gets lost or they can't she's
camera malfunction sorry
so ologist it's like it's almost like
it's fake it's like that guy that got
pushed over you know the old man and
they were like saying waiting here yeah
and they were saying that he got that he
fell like he tripped I'm so glad that
footage came out cuz you see him like
getting pushed another cop wants to go
help him out another guy just stops him
but bro there's still people that think
he's like an actor yeah with a blood bag
with a blood bag like attached to his
bro there's people that think the
[ __ ] wire that cuz he has they don't
like a hearing aid or some [ __ ] whatever
it is people look there are people that
think when he got pushed he's an actor
and you fell hard on purpose to trigger
a [ __ ] blood bag that was attached to
him that make blood come out of his ear
that was like well obviously he was
really old but the way he fell was that
you can't even act that no does that guy
have IMDB he deserves all the YouTube
pranksters later like oh we got a
stranger coming in and the stranger
comes in with the laugh mic in the [ __ ]
[ __ ] that I mean look I'm up and there's
IMDB with all kinds of credits ya know
what kind of [ __ ] stranger is this
guy an actor stranger after trainer
Damian before the shoot day hmm he's
been in more [ __ ] than I am that's
really what's going on
[Music]
you